thank you good morning colleagues uh
thank you very much because of the
sensible and responsible decisions we've
taken to get our economy
recovering from covered in because of
the decisions we took to
come out of lockdown we're in a position
to continue to help people through the
current difficult times and we are now
able to introduce as of tomorrow the
single biggest tax cut in a decade it's
going to be worth 6 billion pounds
altogether saving 30 million british
workers up to 330 pounds per year on
their national insurance contributions
as i say that's coming in uh tomorrow it
will be in people's pay packets from
tomorrow onwards and amongst other
things it is there to help with help
people up another country with the cost
of living and it's part of the 37
billion pounds that we're able to spend
to help people
through the current uh pressures on food
prices on energy prices that we are
seeing and it shows that the government
is firmly on the side of the british
people we're on your side but what we're
doing is not just using our physical
firepower to help people right now we're
also taking the steps that are necessary
to bear down on costs over the medium
and the long term as well reforming our
energy markets reforming our housing
markets uh tackling the costs of of
transport as we are now tackling the
cost of government and everywhere and
always making sure that we get business
get international investors to come and
invest in this country in the way that
they are
at an at an enormous scale uh with the
ambition as you know to make this the
most prosperous economy in europe and
there's one crucial pressure that we
have to uh help alleviate and that is
the pressure on the labor market
and we all know everybody everybody who
talks to any type of of business
and all the public sector knows that the
shortage
of of skilled workers and that's why i
would be remiss of me uh today not once
to not to pay tribute once again to the
department of work and pensions and
tears coffee because i can tell you
colleagues well i didn't tell you last
time that uh actually uh tis tis did
succeed in fulfilling her pledge as she
got 500 000 people from january to june
of welfare into work and what that did
was that saved the taxpayer billions of
pounds
it helped employers
find the workforce that they need and of
course it transformed the lives of half
a million people so thank you very much
cheers and thank you all thank you